Kevin McCarthy has been removed as
Speaker of the House McCarthy is the
first Speaker of the House to be vacated
from his seat in U.S history
shout out to Matt Gates he is doing the
Lord's work I will give you my simple
opinion without bearing the lead in 2022
Republicans want a narrow majority very
a slim majority and Donald Trump was
heavily criticized by establishment
Republicans and conservatives for
tanking them saying it's his fault that
they didn't have the big red wave
because Americans didn't like him I
disagree I think that's not true but
guess what that argument makes no sense
as soon as McCarthy gets in what's
happened what happens he starts cutting
back room deals with Biden and with
Democrats what's the purpose of
Republicans winning a slim majority if
the speaker of the house is going to cut
deals with Democrats instead of his own
party in fact it's people like Matt
Gates that help give the Republican
Party its majority so those arguments
that Donald Trump is the reason there's
no majority meaningless if you're going
to agree that McCarthy should be working
deals with Democrats because then you
may as well just have a Democrat
majority and so this is my this is my
argument against individuals like Thomas
Massey I like Thomas Mass he's a good
dude
let me play this clip for you of what
Massey said in defense of Kevin McCarthy
this is a referendum
on this institution
we have tried regular orders speaker
McCarthy has tried regular order if
regular order fails today if you vacate
the speaker nobody is going to try how
much time has expired institution will
fail I ain't crying about it certainly
not and my understanding is I've seen
reports Lauren bobert supported McCarthy
as did Marjorie Taylor green
I I I respect these individuals I
appreciate the work they do in Congress
but I'm with Matt Gates on this one you
got to keep in mind are these you're not
necessarily supporting the man you're
supporting the office and the function
of the office and maybe what Thomas is
saying is that if if and Kevin
McCarthy's voted out that we won't have
a speaker now and we just won't have one
and like Kevin said I'm not doing it I'm
done other people who who can you even
think of that could do it or would do it
Trump this guy Thomas Massey a lot of
people like that idea Troy Nails tweeted
that he nominates Donald Trump to be
speaker seconded I've got some guy in
the internet though I hope Matt gate
seconds it it doesn't have to be a
congress member it could be anyone so I
I think let's throw uh you know Donald
Duncan there uh Donald Duck let's throw
some mystical characters let's let's
let's let's appoint a dog as the first
Speaker of the House and uh I think the
dog probably would do a way better job
than all the other speaker of the houses
before them when when you when Congress
when the leadership in congress meets
with lobbyists and corporate power in
secret to negotiate deals on what's
going to be in the federal spending Bill
and then
brings out a 5 000 page Omnibus and
tells every member of Congress just sign
it otherwise you're blocking the troops
otherwise veterans aren't getting their
benefits that's blackmail that is
extortion you are you are staring down
these good people in Congress people
like Matt Gates who are saying when he
came on the show last week he said we
want to make sure that we get a bill to
make sure you know disabled veterans
veterans are getting the VA benefits are
coming out we don't want them to miss
these payments right so this is what
they do they they come to a member of
Congress and threaten the vulnerable and
the people who have served this country
and others and the elderly to force you
into funding Lockheed Martin and other
big military industrial complex
corporations how is that an institution
we care about
Matt Gates had a simple proposal
propose what you want to fund and we'll
vote on it that makes a lot of sense
what's the problem the problem is they
know that if they present a bill to
funds say Lockheed Martin to to fund War
it's going to be debated and it's going
to get stonewalled it's going to get
there's going to be delays there's going
to be fights because that's the thing
American people actually want to fight
about but they know if they go to you
and say your kids won't get food your
kid your the poor people won't get
benefits veterans won't get paid then
what happens a guy in a wheelchair shows
up to your office and says why am I why
is my pay getting cut off you're
obstructing the government and you try
to tell them we don't want that for you
we're trying to get that that funding
and then Kevin McCarthy actually says
when they're moving to remove them when
that gets files hey if you're trying to
remove a guy who cut the government open
and got the troops paid we're in a bad
place
it is blackmail for the lobbyists and
the multinational corporations Matt
Gates did a good thing here I feel like
the American people probably learned a
lot today too because oftentimes these
things these Omnibus bills they just get
past like you said Tim and people don't
really understand all they know is that
the national debt is going up that we're
we're sending money overseas that things
are tougher here for for the American
people so maybe they learned a little
bit today and maybe people can can
actually start to talk about these
things you're right it shouldn't just be
everyone is forced into this we should
have a robust debate about it we should
be talking about what is actually being
spent here and and on what and um you
know I I do I think overall this is a
positive thing I feel bad a little bit
for Kevin McCarthy though he has had a
rough go man it was tough for him to get
elected in there I'm sure today wasn't a
great day for him I generally think he's
a nice guy but uh but this was probably
a necessity you know we were talking
about leadership the other day and how
uh there's a lot of stories throughout
history of people who don't want to be
the executive like George Washington no
no I don't want to do like well
someone's got to do it and he's like I
don't wanna okay fine I guess I'll do it
and uh Cincinnatus I think his name was
uh I think that was was it Rome he they
had an emergency said we need someone to
take executive authors I don't want to
do it and they're like you have to he
took power he absorbed he resolved the
emergency and then went right back to
farming and we respect that tremendously
Kevin McCarthy should have recognized
this immediately when there was the
fight over the speakership that either
he was going to have to negotiate and
abide by the terms of his negotiations
or he should not do it at all and he
agreed to terms with what was it 20 some
odd 21 members of Congress who are
saying we want to negotiate these
specific terms otherwise we won't
support you one of those one of those
terms my understanding was not to cut
back room deals with Democrats if Kevin
McCarthy wants to
go back on his word and his word is
meaningless then I don't think he's a
good guy and he should have said
immediately guys it will be impossible
for me to do this deal with you I'm not
going to be speaker and this never would
have happened you know as you're talking
about all these people who are like I
don't want to be in this position I I'm
not the right one I actually feel like
if you go back and look at my
father-in-law for years ago I mean we're
talking like the 80s the Oprah
interviews the 90s he said for so long I
don't want to do it but if there ever
came a time where things got so bad I
felt like I had no other choice I would
run for president and amazing to see
that he did it what he did while he was
President the way they fought against
him what is happening now all of it but
as you were saying that that's that's
the only person that came to my mind
because he I don't I mean to see what
he's given up and the hell he's gone
through man what what is his uh his net
worth dropped oh I'm I don't know how
much especially significant especially
with the judge attacking Mar-A-Lago
which is really weird for a New York
judge to be like it's worth less and
it's like okay well I think uh Trump is
one of the rare politicians whose net
worth has declined by joining public
office where typically you see Dianne
Feinstein being with 150 million dollars
after being in Congress and the Pelosi's
are with 200 million dollars so you know
I'll give you my my my personal view is
yeah there's a big difference between
George Washington and Donald Trump a
little bit right just a coach but I've
we've seen all the interviews of of
trump being asked since the 80s and we
even had that um who was it was it it
was Trump was on a talk show with uh I
can't remember who it was it was one of
those morning shows and there I think
who was it uh they were like you gotta
run Donald it wasn't the Oprah interview
there was another one and he was like
well you know I don't know about that
probably morning jokes
yes Roseanne was encouraging him oh well
she's still a fan he's been encouraged a
lot and he would always say no but but
back to the main story I think we have
this tweet uh pulled up I think it's
actually the second that I pull this up
Congressman Troy Nails he's a big dude
we've had him on the show several times
says Kevin McCarthy will not be running
again as Speaker I nominate Donald J
Trump for Speaker of the House
please and Matt Gates did this the first
time around second it and you know I
just
I I don't see the excuse for any member
of Congress
to to not go for bold changes in DC the
concern is if someone nominates Oprah
and then they win like because it's a
popularity contest well all the
Democrats are like we need somebody
famous to get everyone to say yes to it
I get that but Republicans aren't going
to play that game yeah and if
Republicans have the majority and can
win if they just agree how about the
former Republican president well does it
only take eight Republicans to side with
the Democrats to push someone in or nine
I think it's uh five or six I think even
I think it's not five or six I think it
was it might be 11.
if Trump were to take it you know would
uh would he still be able to run for
president as the speaker of the house or
is that a conflict that I don't know
it's a good question I don't see why not
because he's not a member of Congress he
would just be speaker I'd be really
interesting and even even if he were a
member of Congress he could still run
for president you know I know it's just
not reality but people were talking
about a few years ago like Steve Bannon
was saying nominate Trump for speaker
vote him and his speaker and then when
you impeach Biden and convict Biden and
Kamala Trump becomes a president what
are the what are the qualifications for
the speaker like what are the the main
things you need from that person what do
you mean like uh Charisma do you need
intelligence you need like those are
probably favorable yeah Connections in
business in the industry um or is that
actually a bad thing like uh so how do
you want these people do you want them
to be like
I I would say their qualifications the
requirements not necessarily
qualifications because that implies like
a procedural thing but the the
characteristics we're looking for in any
leader is going to be Integrity honesty
transparency to the best of their
abilities I understand we have security
issues something completely lacking in
Congress that no one you know very few
people have in there but but I think
someone that doesn't uh roll over on
their back and let the Democrats have
their way with them I think that's the
first thing I think anyone that's not a
rhino anyone that's not a
neoconservative anyone who doesn't want
to perpetuate the larger proxy war in
Ukraine right now I think this is a
larger kind of referendum against
Congress failing the American people
throughout many years now they never
represented the will of what people
actually wanted there was never a public
referendum on if we should start a proxy
war in Ukraine there was never a
referendum on the debt ceiling Kevin
McCarthy another thing he did he made it
that the the Biden Administration could
print and borrow as much money as they
want until 2025. right now just a few
days ago the debt went up 2 275 billion
dollars in just one day it is set to
increase to almost one trillion dollars
in just one month it just hit 33
trillion dollars America is being
destroyed by a lot of the corporate
influences that have hijacked Congress
and this is a referendum saying we had
enough stop it thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time